ich bin froh dass ich mir die Arbeit
gemacht habe mit der Nudeln
denn die haben einfach eine krasse
Konsistenz und Sinn oder
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres herzhaftes
Gericht wir hatten mal wieder Lust auf
was türkisches und ihr könnt ja oder ihr
kennt ja Mante sind so kleine gefüllte
Teigtaschen mit Joghurtsoße mega mega
lecker heute gibt es aber gefälschte
Mantel Jordan jumante und zwar gibt es
bei uns tatsächlich bei Mama recht oft
dass man Nudeln abkocht eine
Hackfleischsoße dazu und Joghurt dazu
richtig lecker ihr könnt das ganze gerne
mit fertigen Nudeln machen also einfach
Nudeln eurer Wahl Fach Falle Penne egal
was aber so richtig genial wird wenn ihr
erwischte dazu macht er ist der Nudeln
sind aus dem türkischen auch so kleine
Nudeln und normalerweise ist es immer
ein bisschen aufwendig denn ich weiß
noch von meiner Mama die kneten alle den
Teig per Hand dann wird es mit dem
oklava als Teig ausgerollt dann
zugeschnitten kleine Nudeln gemacht ich
zeige euch heute wie ihr die Nudeln
wirklich blitzschnell selber machen
könnt entweder habt ihr eine
Küchenmaschine für oder eben auch eine
nudelwalze geht beides sehr gut deswegen
finde ich ist eigentlich nicht mehr so
aufwendig für die Zutaten oder für den
Teig habe ich hier einfach 500 Gramm
Mehl drei Eier Wasser und Salz beim
Wasser kommt gleich einfach nur drauf an
wie viel oder wie groß die Eier sind
deswegen kann ich euch da jetzt keine
genaue Menge machen aber ich zeige euch
das jetzt mal hier
also ich nehme den Knethaken und
normalerweise wenn ihr das schon macht
dann könnt ihr auch gleich eine größere
Portion machen die Nudeln trocknen
lassen und habe dann immer erdichte auf
Vorrat auch gut sind auch gut in so
einer Suppe zum Beispiel ich gebe jetzt
erstmal die Hälfte des Mehls in die
Rührschüssel
dann die Eier dazu
dann das Salz
und jetzt schön kneten und dann gebe ich
immer wieder Mehl dazu und nach Bedarf
Wasser und soll dann einfach ein schöner
fester Teig entstehen der nicht klebt
also kein weicher Hefeteig sondern
wirklich ein schöner fester Nudelteig
und ich muss sagen Nudelteig knete ich
lieber mit der Küchenmaschine nicht mit
den Händen weil es schon fester Teig ist
so sieht jetzt der fertige Teig aus der
ist schön weich nicht so fest aber auch
nicht zu weich den lasse ich jetzt kurz
ruhen ich packe den dann gerne in etwas
bienenwachstuch ein ein bienenwachstuch
quasi so Frischhaltefolien und Alufolien
Ersatz man kann es nämlich immer wieder
benutzen einfach ein bisschen
nachhaltiger und wenn es
bienenwachstücher später so ein bisschen
brüchig werden dann bügelt ihr einfach
drüber also ihr packt es zwischen
Backpapier zum Beispiel Bügel drüber und
dann ist es wieder schön geschmeidig da
lasse ich es jetzt stehen und kann mich
dann
ich ruhe mich jetzt so lang aus denn mit
den Nudeln geht es dann erst weiter
später die Hackfleischsoße und dann der
Joghurt
also der Teig ist hier und jetzt könnt
ihr entweder die ganz normalen Walzen
nehmen oder die extra große Walze das
extra so eine lasagnewalze die mega gut
ist vor allem wenn ihr nur die Walze
habt dann nehmt die dann habt ihr eine
richtig große Fläche könnt den ganzen
Tag auf einmal ausrollen und später dann
zum Beispiel mit einem Messer oder Pizza
Roller oder mit einem bisschen Klett die
Nudeln schneiden wenn ihr aber die
Nudeln mit der Maschine ausschneiden
wollt weil ihr zum Beispiel die
Fettuccine Walzer habt dann nehmt ihr
einfach die ganz normale Lasagne Walze
weil dann passt es einfach so von der
Breite perfekt zusammen
vorne nämlich schön an den Anschluss
zack
dann ist das Nudeln machen wirklich
einfach
das bienenwachstuch kann man jetzt schön
abwaschen trocknen lassen und später
wieder benutzen
ein bisschen Mehl
dann halbiere ich mal den Teig
die Hälfte einpacken dass sie nicht
trocknet
und wenn ihr ein bisschen Mehl braucht
das ist okay wenn ihr zu viel Mehl
braucht heißt es der Teig ist einfach zu
feucht und zu nass dann müsste er ein
bisschen fester geknetet werden
und dann fange ich jetzt hier an bei
Stufe 0 das ist die gröbste Einstellung
und arbeite mich dann voran aber ich
zeige euch jetzt wie man das so macht
dass die Platten wirklich exakt und
perfekt werden
also erstmal den Teig durchlassen
muss auch nicht gleich perfekt aussehen
es kann auch sein dass man vielleicht
mal reißt ist gar nicht schlimm jetzt
falte ich ihn zusammen
und gebe mit den geraden Flächen hier
nach außen
das mache ich jetzt noch einmal dann
weiß ich dass er einfach schön
geschmeidig ist
und wenn ihr dann zufrieden seid geht
ihr jetzt hier eine Stufe weiter auf die
dann die zwei
dann gehe ich auf die drei und das könnt
ihr soweit machen
je dünner ihr die Nudeln haben wollt wow
wie funktioniert das jetzt egal ich
glaube ich gehe so bis auf Stufe 5 und
dann werde ich sie zuschneiden je höher
die Stufe umso dünner die Nudel aber zu
dünn wollen wir ehrlichste nicht haben
also nicht wie bei anderen Nudeln
dann halbiere ich das jetzt hier kurz
einfach damit einfacher ist für die
Handhabung
habe zwar lange aber so lange dann doch
nicht die lege ich kurz da vorne ab
und kann mich mit der zweiten Teig
kümmern
dann nehme ich die cd-walze raus und ich
mache es immer so ich lasse die jetzt
einfach in der Küche trocknen und falls
Ihr hier noch Teigreste habt könnt ihr
die später einfach mit einer Bürste Weg
Bürsten da nämlich niemals mit Wasser
dran so macht ihr euch die Walzen kaputt
aber wie gesagt einfach auf trocknen
lassen wegbürsten da ist alles wieder
sauber jetzt nehme ich hier den Aufsatz
für Fettuccine aber ihr könnt auch jetzt
hergehen und ein Pizza Rad nehmen ein
Messer ein bisschen glatt ich glaube ich
zeige es euch einmal kurz mit ein
bisschen zum Beispiel
und wir machen so kleine Nudeln man
könnte die einmal quer halbieren
und dann das bisseglätt gar nicht
auseinander ziehen sondern hier einfach
so schneiden
und dann habt ihr hier eure Nudeln und
ewig das sind eigentlich ein bisschen
dünner
aber es ist okay aber ihr könnt auch
gerne halbieren so wie Ihr möchtet
fettenschiene Aufsatz macht dann könnte
entweder jetzt lange Nudeln machen oder
eben auch kurze ich mache das jetzt so
damit ich sie nicht danach schneiden
muss schneide ich vorher die Platte
macht das ganze hier an
und dann kommen die geschnitten wieder
raus
also ich mag das Nudeln selber machen
immer gern so ein bisschen Mehl
dazwischen das nichts klebt
[Musik]
Anna
hervorragend
da ist meine
edelste Produktion
die lasse jetzt hier einfach bei
Raumtemperatur stehen die dürfen gerne
ein bisschen antrocknen aufpassen dass
sie nicht kleben aber ich habe
eigentlich die mit genug Abstand aufs
Blech gesetzt und falls ihr die trocknen
wollt dann entweder auf so einem großen
Baumwolltuch oder im Dörrautomaten das
geht auch jetzt mache ich hier sauber
und werde jetzt schon mal die
Hackfleischsoße zubereiten
für die Hackfleischsoße verwende ich 500
Gramm Hackfleisch vom Rind eine Zwiebel
etwas Olivenöl hier habe ich etwas
Tomatenmark und Paprikamark 200 g Wasser
und meine Gewürzmischung ich nehme Salz
und Pfeffer etwas keckig also
bergbohnenkraut Paprika in edelsüß oder
auch gerne scharf und etwas Minze wenn
ihr das ganze jetzt mit fertigen Nudeln
zubereitet dann fängt eigentlich jetzt
erst euer Kochprozess an denn dann müsst
ihr vorher keine Nudeln zubereiten dann
nehmt ihr jetzt die Zutaten ich habe
jetzt hier einen gusseisentopf den
erhitze ich jetzt mit etwas Olivenöl
ich hatte auch gestern hier im Team so
das Gespräch wann gusseisentopf wann
Eisen wann
Teflonpfanne also wabenpfanne und ich
nehme immer einen gusseisentopf bei
allem was scharf angebraten wird und was
eben viel Geschmack erhalten sollte das
heißt zum Beispiel Hackfleisch was eben
schön scharf angebraten wird Zwiebeln
die schönen glasig werden und eben auch
Geschmack bekommen das mache ich immer
alles in Gusseisen in der beschichteten
Pfannen wie zum Beispiel der wabenpfanne
da brate ich eigentlich nur Dinge an die
etwas zart sind also Gemüse zum Beispiel
oder Fisch wenn ich Sucuk macht dann
mache ich das auch ein Gusseisen also so
trenne ich das immer so ein bisschen
voneinander weil eine beschichtete
Pfanne einfach länger lebt wenn sie
nicht so Rätsel erhitzt wird und gerade
eine Gusseisenpfanne eben dafür gedacht
ist das hoch erhitzt wird also könnte da
ruhig ich mache jetzt auch die Lüftung
schon mal an
volle Pulle Gas geben und das
Hackfleisch schön anbraten schön
krümelig nicht zerkleinert dann immer
hier mit dem Walker
[Musik]
und wenn ihr generell noch fragen habt
wann welcher top welche Pfanne oder
welches Kochgeschirr verwendet wird dann
schreibt mir gerne eure Fragen in die
Kommentare denn dann kann ich auch drauf
eingehen
und der wacker da ist zerkleinert das
jetzt immer damit es nicht ein großer
hackballen wird sondern wirklich schön
krümelig ist
währenddessen gern schon mal die Zwiebel
hacken
[Musik]
wenn es hier unten so ein bisschen
anbrennt ist es auch gar nicht schlimm
[Musik]
jetzt ist das Hackfleisch schön krümelig
und später wird sich dieses leicht
angebrannte auch wieder lösen wenn ich
dann die Flüssigkeit dazu gebe also
deswegen ich liebe Gusseisen und ich
befürworte es auch immer denn darin
kommt einfach der beste Geschmack
zustande
das haue ich hier noch die Zwiebeln mit
rein mach schnell den Deckel zu denn
heute war aber stark
schnell rein mit anbraten
dann riecht sie nicht so und falls ihr
euch wundert warum mein Tomaten und
Paprika mag so aussieht ich hole es
immer in großer Menge füllst dann in
Eiswürfel portioniere ein also in diese
Eiswürfelbehälter und friere es ein und
dann kann ich immer am Tomatenmark und
Paprika mag einfach schön portionieren
das habe dann immer diese kleinen
Würfelchen und habe dann immer eine
schöne Portion
das dauert jetzt so etwa zwei drei
Minuten
so sieht es schon super aus jetzt kommen
Tomatenmark und Paprika dazu dann das
Wasser und die Gewürze und das war's
schon in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr auch
gerne schon mal nudelwasser aufsetzen
und es nach dem Kochen dann direkt
salzig also nach dem Aufkochen des
Wassers Salz
dann kommt der Deckel wieder drauf und
weil Gusseisen die Hitze gut speichert
ziehe ich sie jetzt schon mal vom Herd
runter wenn ihr in den normalen Topf
kocht einfach noch zwei drei Minuten
köcheln lassen allerdings werde ich
jetzt hier schon mal weiterarbeiten und
hier das Wasser kochen das ist gleich
soweit hier Butter schmelzen und da
kommt gleich Paprika dazu und zwar süßes
Paprikapulver
das ist dann nämlich das Topping dann
kann ich schon mal alles andere
vorbereiten die habe ich Joghurt da gebe
ich jetzt etwas Salz Pfeffer und
Knoblauch dazu das verrühre ich einfach
im Becher
und sobald dann die Nudeln gekocht sind
ist alles soweit also ein schönes
schnelles einfaches Rezept
[Musik]
einfach immer so kurz aufschäumern das
reicht dann schon
meistens schwimmen die Nudeln dann oben
wenn Sie fertig sind ihr könnt ja
einfach mal probieren und dann euch die
Hände verbrennen
perfekt abgießen fertig
ist das Essen und ich sag's euch wie es
ist bei uns in der Türkei wird es
eigentlich so angerichtet das jetzt
alles auf ein großes Blech kommt
also auf eine große Servierplatte erst
die Nudeln dann die Hackfleischsoße dann
der Joghurt und am Ende die Soße ich
werde es allerdings anders anrichten ich
muss auch sagen zu corona-zeiten oder zu
Zeiten Ideen aber vielleicht ein
bisschen besser aufpassen oder werden
mit wem ist sollte man vielleicht doch
auf einzelnen Portionen anrichten finde
ich persönlich immer ein bisschen
appetitlicher
denn ich esse nicht so gern von anderen
Menschen auf dem gleichen Teller du
[Musik]
bei uns gibt es jeden fast jeden Sonntag
echt ja und alle Essen immer aus dem aus
dem aus dem Blech aus dem Blech und ich
habe irgendwann einen eigenen Teller
ich mache das als Kind auch nicht so
ich bin da so von meiner von meiner
deutschen Oma so ein bisschen geprägt
diese Mann nein immer auf den Teller ist
viel besser weiß man auch wie viel
Portion man halt auch ist okay probiere
es jetzt mal anders anzurichten weil
eigentlich sind türkische Rezepte oft
immer gleich aus weil irgendwie Joghurt
Berg drauf ist und die Paprika okay ich
probiere es jetzt mal andersrum
okay wir haben jetzt gerade gesagt wir
probieren nicht gern vom gleichen Teller
in meinen Videos probieren halt immer
meistens gehen wir nicht noch mal mit
der Gabe rein
richtig schön anzurichten
ich sag's euch das schmeckt so geil ich
weiß schon dass es zu gut schmeckt
dann haben wir hier die Nudeln
und die schmecken halt einfach
selbstgemacht anders als gekauft muss
man halt dazu sagen
ein bisschen Soße
kann man ja auch gerne flüssiger machen
wenn man möchte
ich bin ja ich bin ja eigentlich kein
Hackfleisch Fan bzw allgemein so
Rindfleisch und so nur wenn es man
Rumpsteak ist dann im Restaurant aber
das liebe ich es schmeckt einfach so gut
das hat auch was die Kinder die Lieben
ich bin froh dass ich mir die Arbeit
gemacht habe mit der Nudeln
denn die haben einfach eine krasse
Konsistenz und sind oder
oh mein Gott
wenn ich nach Hause komme ich will es
auch
lecker oh mein Gott kommt den Teller
darfst du behalten danke
und ich richte das jetzt hier noch an
für uns alle ich hoffe euch gefällt
dieses Rezept mir gefällt es richtig gut
man kann es hervorragend vorbereiten
gerade die Nudeln aber auch so klappt es
wirklich sehr sehr gut muss ich sagen
ich mache viel zu selten Nudeln selber
also falls ihr auch mal wieder mehr
Nudelrezepte haben wollt schreibt mir
gerne in die Kommentare dann können wir
mal gerne wieder ein bisschen mehr Pasta
Rezepte machen würde ich sagen das
Rezept findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
und bis zum nächsten Mal und
rezeptwünsche sind immer willkommen
macht's gut
[Musik]